Today we're doing something different (WE ARE HERE TOO)
Today we're talking about someone
In a positive light! YAYYYY (YAY)
(Happy Pewds Noises)
First time on this channel!
Keanu Reeves everyone! Internet's new favourite character
Everyone's favourite badass good guy
I know, I know, I have done alot of videos on him (Iconic weird Pewds accent)
But I have been diggin' a little deeper into Keanu Reeves, and its some pretty fascinating fun stuff
That we can go through together, let's go
I am sure you have already seen the abundance of memes that happened during the past couple days
Keanu has taken over the internet
But what makes Keanu so likeable, why does everyone love this guy
Number 1: Keanu ALWAYS knows what to say
In any situation Keanu will have the perfect answer
"What is your secret for always staying down-to-earth?"
"Well, I mean.. Gravity
(Starts laughing at his own joke because it is funny, don't judge)
I like how he laughs at his own joke too
(Chuckles)
"What do you thinks happens when we die Keanu Reeves?"
(Auidence laughs)
(DEEP Keanu sigh)
"I know that, the ones who love us will miss us"
(Audience cheers and applauds)
"John Wick Chapter 3!"
So good!
So how does he get this wisdom?
Well, of course, Keanu Reeves Number 2 reason why he's so likeable
He is immortal, everyone knows this
It's just an indisputable fact at this point
look at this portrait, early 1500s, portrait of a man
(pewds and audience laugh)
what is this that is going on
yeah he is like - its a gang sign, its a gang sign
what is he doing
he had a lot of weird finger things
you tell us Keanu, its literally you